[Music]
hello everyone don't worry we have not
changed our set this is just a new set
but we'll tell you all about that in a
while Martin what's going on here what's
all this funny stuff on this table well
I think uh people like modern and new
and funky
yeah well what are we
doing you will see our backdrop looks a
little bit different modern you look
very funny over there with those glasses
I've got glasses on and you've lost
yours and I I think I'm I'm practicing
to grow mustache again over there I
don't know what's going
on but let us tell you the
story we have decided it that it's time
that we reach a broader
audience and people have so many
questions and they have so many personal
questions and we have been trying to
answer these questions and we've had
people working around the clock full
time just answering questions and one
cannot keep
up so Martin the fellow behind you over
there yes his name is Marlo Marlo Marlo
Smith he's You're A Smith too does that
mean he's a relative yes he's my cousin
he's your cousin yes all right Maro has
been working for us for more than 3
years he was a teacher a mathematics
teacher and he decided to put his whole
weight behind the Lord's work and he's
been answering questions
full-time for 3 years now and the one
behind me is my wayward son who we've
introduced to you already right with
that wonderful testimony and if you
haven't seen it please go and check on
our YouTube site so my way with son has
decided that it is time to put his
weight behind the ministry as well
because time is very very short and we
want to reach a wider audience
so this set that you see is not the
WhatsApp Prof set no WhatsApp Prof is
not going to change it's going to stay
exactly the same so we have some good
news and we have some bad
news what's the bad news I don't think
it's bad I think it's great all the way
all the way okay so it's great news let
us tell you what we will do we're going
to
alternate one week will be what is truth
with these young folks reaching out to
an audience that uh we might not reach
in any other way where they will also
have testimonies and discuss questions
and relevance and the times we are
living in on a on a different level than
WhatsApp
Prof and we will alternate every second
week will be WhatsApp Prof and every
second week will be every alternative
week will be the these two young
gentlemen and uh they're starting out
with their Venture they are working
independently and uh I think we should
give them a little bit of support cut
them a little bit of slack yeah and hope
that uh they'll get into the groove
quickly yeah remember if you watch the
first probably 100 episodes I was also
not very um talkative yet yes you were
also quite nervous yeah in the beginning
the Lord is very gracious yes and we
need lots of prayers because the the
enemy is really walking around like a
roaring lion all right another reason
why we came up with this idea is that
the ministry has been
expanding not because we intended it to
expand it just happened that way so now
there's this health arm which is Varity
we have all these Evangelistic teams we
must show you what's happening and the
amazing Miracles that are taking place
in the darkest area of the world totally
unreached areas and we'll keep you
updated and tell you what's happening on
that on that level as well it's really
amazing and we are so busy and we have
got camp meetings and we have this and
it just takes a toll to produce a
WhatsApp Prof every single week M and uh
it just wears you down eventually and uh
you realize you know we have to conserve
strength but we must get the message out
there's an urgency so if we can do that
Martin every second week it'll cut us
some slack and give us some time to do
all the other things that we have to do
and still be uh producing a WhatsApp
Prof every second second we relevant
still not fall behind in what's
happening in the news with prophecy
being fulfilled and
also like you mentioned earlier we
didn't plan for any of this the Lord
just shows
us one day we just said okay this is
what we think the Lord wants to do and
here it is we were discussing how to
answer all the questions of the people
and we and WhatsApp Prof have done a few
questions and answers in the past and
when we do the questions and answers
then people receive their answers but we
can't answer them all no and if we have
uh young people discussing their
problems and sending in their
testimonies this might just be the tool
to reach that audience which uh we with
our methodology might just not be able
to reach amen so as from right now after
we've spoken you will see we will go
over to what is truth so the next
broadcast will be what is truth and the
one following it will be WhatsApp Prof
and it will be the same set as we
normally use this is just a little bit
of a funky one for the younger audience
perhaps hopefully so will you pray for
this new Endeavor and all of these
programs that we are going to put forth
Heavenly Father you have laid it upon
our hearts to produce a series where
personal questions personal issues
issues of Truth and what is truth can be
discussed in a somewhat different
forum and I pray Lord that you will
bless the Venture that you will bless
the the people that are involved that
they may receive the Enlightenment from
the Holy Spirit they are on fire they
want to spread your word they love the
truth and uh all of them were Wayward at
one stage and the world out there is
totally Wayward and this might just be
the
spark that can touch some hearts that
will not be necessarily moved by other
methods so bless this Venture Lord and
bless the audience and I pray that they
also will pray for this Venture so that
the final message can go out because the
urgency is great the time is short so
help us Lord send your spirit we pray in
jesus' name amen amen
[Music]
[Applause]
good day to all our viewers and a very
warm welcome to this new series called
what is
truth sure today we have in the studio
myself uh Robert fight and on my left my
good friend I'm Marlo Smith hi Marlo how
you doing today I'm good and you I am
good I'm good I'm feeling very blessed I
don't know about you but wow I'm blessed
to embark on this journey and to work
for the Lord hey yeah what a what a
privilege what a privilege it is what a
privilege and yeah and we've we've been
talking about this for a while it's been
a journey to get to this point but we
are finally here and I'm very excited
incredibly yeah it was it started out um
with us jogging or you you were busy
jogging and you sent me a video and said
when am I when am I going to join you
you you've been here for how long for
you've lived in this area for about 2
and 1/ half years yeah two years two
years mine it's just over a year and uh
I remember I went for a jog with my dog
and and I said you know what Maro looks
like a like a nice guy let's ask him to
come and jog with with me so but yeah
before we get into everything why don't
we start with with a prayer okay dear
Lord thank you for everything that you
do in our lives and Lord we are
embarking on this new journey and it's
and it's something we want to do for you
and we want to study together and we
want to we want to talk about truth and
Lord it's important in these in these in
this day and age to to be to be embedded
in the truth so Lord uh guide our
discussions today Enlighten us and and
thank you for everything in Jesus name
amen amen so yeah so are we going to are
we going to talk a little bit about what
we what we are going to do what this
series is about and and what the name
stands for and the the slogan as well oh
yes so are yeah so share with the
viewers a bit what what's this program
about
so what we want to do what we want to
achieve is we want to involve our
viewers you know we want to talk we want
to unravel and we want to discuss and
and search you know we want to talk
about truth and what it entails and not
just that we also want to create a a a
collaborative platform yeah where where
we want to invite the viewers to make it
a bit more personal yes so we want the
viewers me to make it more collaborative
yeah so we want in the future it should
be based on questions and to help people
find answers for their questions so we
want the people to pick up their cell
phone put it on video and then record a
video and ask us their question stating
their name what the question are where
they're from so that we can have this
connection with them other than just
sending us an email and we read it and
we don't actually know the person or how
the person actually looks that sent in
the question no that'll be good yeah and
and we will obviously post it on the did
you mention we'll post it on the on the
show and we'll we'll we can you know
collaborate on that we can see you on
the screen and we can talk about your
question and we can really discuss it I
mean we are humans like you and I are
humans we don't we don't have all the
answers but that's why we're here to
discuss and to to really get involved
together um so then why what is truth
why did why did we decide on that that
name because in this day and age truth
is is is a is a real scarcity and we we
want to unravel what it actually means
and we want to actually use the Bible to
do so to really understand what was
meant uh when pilate actually asked uh
you know what is truth he really wanted
to know and and it's uh he had this
Yearning For Truth at that point when
Jesus was standing in front of him yeah
and and when you look at truth if you
search just for the definition on the
internet um Oxford dictionary says the
true facts about something rather than
the things that have been invented or
guessed dictionary.com actually has 11
definitions of what is truth wow so so
it's an important matter and it's such a
such a big matter yeah yeah yeah sure so
because everyone is looking for truth it
is but there's only one place where we
can find it Google has billions of
searches daily so people like
information they want to find out things
when you go to school they teach you
truth yeah based on TR worldly views so
how according to them so how do you know
that that is actual truth because
science has different views depending on
the era that you lived in um
in history there was people that had the
idea that things could be created
spontaneously like in The Big Bang
Theory and they based their reason off
of you had a piece of meat and all of a
sudden you had maggots in the meat
because they didn't refrigerate it or
something like that so they said the
maggots spontaneously showed up in the
meat yeah yeah but then later on
realized okay but it's because of the
Flies that you had the maggots yeah so
there's new truth there's new truth so
you have so you yeah so the world in the
world you can't have absolute truth you
know you have you have deception and you
have truth yeah it it's Progressive but
truth has always been the same since the
beginning up until the end our knowledge
of it is just expanding yes if you look
for instance at Martin Luther
um he didn't believe at the stage of
baptism by submersion submersion yeah so
the people who were doing it at that
stage were actually persecuted because
they were seen as Heretics yeah you had
all these little lights that sprang up
you know Martin Luther has you know
faith and then you had the Baptist and
and they were all in in loggerheads with
one another you know at at the start but
they all had pieces of truth and those
truths just had to be combined to create
the full story the full truth and and
where we are now yeah there's actually a
brilliant series your father does um
Professor F and that is called conflict
and Triumph and that's about the history
and how these different Church movements
corre formed into one
movement all these different truths
coming together and it's just amazing
how it works and how God LED this
movement you know from the beginning
Right Through the Ages to this point
yeah no it's interesting and and well if
you look at the I guess call it a slogan
Beyond personal you know it is I mean we
want to make this personal you know it's
a personal Journey that we're going to
embark on and uh and you know we we want
our viewers also down the line we want
to we want to uh create an opportunity
for testimonies so we can we can listen
to testimonies and we can talk about it
and see how God has led us in in our
lives and throughout this this whole
series I think we are going to uh we're
going to point to that you know we're
going to allude to to our lives as well
and how it relates to truth I guess yeah
and we live in an era where people only
think about themselves it's so such a
selfish centered yes the self-centered
era and everyone if you go on to YouTube
and you see videos it's promoting self
it's what can I do how can I influence
the world into a certain direction yeah
yeah but it goes beyond that it's not
about us it's about God and and before
you know Jesus when he came to Earth I
mean he he wasn't self-centered at all
there was Zero of self you know centrism
in his in his life and as an example and
that's why I believe and going yeah like
you said going beyond the personal
is you know although it's personal and
although it's you know its feelings and
its emotion and all of this we have to
stick to the guidelines that God has
provided us with you know his law and
and um because why why why did he
provide us with the guidelines to you
know to is it a tyrannical God or is it
to to uh protect us you know and uh
provide us with safety and and uh give
us a life that that we'll enjoy you know
so yeah and and that character of God
has been attacked so the truth about God
isn't out there in the world the truth
is how a lot of people see it and that's
how Satan wants the people to see it
yeah God is rful he
arbitrary he yeah he's exacting yeah
yeah he's controlling exactly yeah and
it's actually the opposite of that from
the start with Adam and Eve already he
started deceiving deceiving them into
believing that God is is this wrathful
person that you know that if you that
that he just he's he's self-centered you
know he doesn't want you to eat the
fruit because he will because you will
become like God hey interesting it's
like God is hiding something from you
and he doesn't want you to find it yeah
exactly actually that's Satan that's
exactly what he is doing he's hiding all
the light that has been given to us God
doesn't do anything in darkness no it's
only Satan who does it yeah and this
devil or Satan doesn't care how he
deceives people as long as he can
deceive you but God just wants you to
have the whole truth and you can make a
decision based on the truth and and
Satan does doesn't care if you if you
despise him or love him whatever the
case may be it doesn't matter as long as
you lost as long as he can hurt uh God
then he's happy where God he cannot
force he cannot you know he he he can
only hope that what he gives you is is
something that you'll accept and that
you'll want to be with him and that
you'll love him yeah yeah
so so truth back to truth I mean
it's a scarcity in this world like I
said before and and if we're not
anchored to the
Rock then we're going to live a very
unhappy life although we all think it's
we're happy it's not always the case you
know and it's confusing if you look at
the state of the world these days people
are confused they don't know they have
no idea what is happening you know they
haven't been subjected to the truth and
they haven't been watching and praying
you know so they there's there's a
confusion and and they there's a fear
not a fear for God but a fear for for uh
events and fear for you know because
there's no truth there's no truth in
them unfortunately yeah and and I mean
what does what does uh Babylon actually
mean what is the definition of Babylon
it means confusion exactly correct so
who would want to create the confusion
yeah Satan Satan and I've got this quote
here that comes from a series
testimonies for the church yeah and it
says we are living in an age of great
light but much that is called light is
opening the way for the wisdom and arts
of Satan many things will be presented
that appear to be true and yet they need
to be carefully considered with much
prayer for they may be specious devices
of the enemy the path of error often
appears to lie close to the path of
Truth
it is hardly distinguishable from the
path that leads to Holiness and heaven
but the Mind enlightened by the Holy
Spirit May discern that it is diverging
from the right way after a while the two
are seen to be widely
separated so the devil is smart he had
6,000 years to plan to perfect his plan
and well he creates the falsity or the
lie to be so close to the truth that
it's difficult to discern because if
you're going to go to someone and tell
them a huge lie they're immediately
going to say no how we're not going to
believe this comparative to the Drop of
Poison you know that you throw the whole
bowl or a whole bucket of I don't know
orange juice or something you know
there's there's a bit of I mean it would
kill you over time and that's exactly
what's happening to this world it's been
almost 6,000 years and uh and here we
are in a in a state yeah wretched State
and and there's supposed to be one truth
yeah one truth exactly exactly and uh I
mean how
many yeah how many how many
denominations are there out there hey if
you look at the the main categories
forget about the subcategories the main
categories are Christianity you have
Islam you have Judaism you have Hinduism
and you have
Buddhism and just a quick search earlier
on on Google uh
Christianity amounts to around 31%
somewhere around there and uh Islam
takes the the other 50% so it's about
20% Islam
so if you think about it I mean that is
31% Christianity and how many
denominations do we have out there and
another search revealed around 4,000 it
could be more I mean just one search
said 4,000 I don't actually know but
other search there 10 there are
thousands of of denominations out
there it it just feels like we are back
we are back at the Reformation where we
just completely divided yeah and every
single denomination feels that they have
the truth yeah every religion feels like
they have the truth yeah so how can you
then go and
say my religion is true yeah what is it
based
on yeah based on it it has to be based
on lies and how how I mean Mo all the
all the denominations are seemingly
based on on the word but but if we if we
interpret it incorrect or if we
interpret it to suit our own Lifestyles
then we are going to have the wrong
picture of God like the Pharisees of old
did they have the right picture of Jesus
Christ when he arrived on Earth no they
did not yeah yeah you can basically find
in the Bible anything to
justify what you want to
do but then it's taken out of context
and you have to place it back into
context to find out what the whole truth
is yeah so one truth changes into
thousands of truths yeah because you
want to justify what you do yeah and and
how do
we how do we get to to the truth you
know there's there's if if we read in
John
14:6 I am the truth the way and the life
so Jesus Christ is the way and the life
and
um no one else comes to the father
except through him and that's I mean if
you look at uh some of the the top five
categories I mean not many believe that
Jesus Christ is who he was or who he
says he he is you know um
and Ephesians 4:5 says one Lord One
Faith one baptism you know and and in
spirit of Prophecy volume 4 it reads
instead of one Lord One Faith one
baptism there are numberless conflicting
Creeds and theories religious Faith
appears so confused and discordant that
the world know not what to believe as
truth God is not in all this it is the
work of man M she says it's the it's the
work of
Satan yeah so it's
crazy it is and is it easy to accept the
truth it is not it's clearly not easy to
accept the truth if it was then the
majority of this world would be
following the truth would be living a a
life of righteousness and Holiness yeah
imagine imagine how it would be in a
city or how it would be to just walk
around and everyone kept the truth
everyone were of the same mind everyone
were yeah everyone had the same mindset
everyone oh it would be nice loved each
other everyone had that other centered
love
but that would not be the case for most
people in this world that's not what
they want you know it's a foreign
concept to them you know um Holiness and
righteousness and acting in a righteous
fashion you know um yeah today there are
so many well deception has caused um has
caused sin to accelerate and
magnify and and I believe we're living
in the last days because that's that's
where we are now you know it
feels exactly like was prescribed about
the days of
that's where we are living now and the
days of lot we know look at all the look
at the you know the developments in the
world today it is very similar you know
people are are mocking truth and they
are accepting error yeah they are and
speaking about the last days in
manuscript releases volume 13 we read uh
we are now living in the last days when
the truth must be spoken BR en when in
reproof and warning it must be given to
the world irrespective of
consequences if there are some who will
become offended and turn from the truth
we must bear in mind that there were
those who did the same in Jesus's day
when the greatest teacher the world has
ever known spoke the truth many of his
disciples became offended and walked no
more with them but the truth will bear
away the victory those who will maintain
the truth irrespective of consequences
will offend some whose hearts are not in
harmony with the truth as it is in Jesus
these persons cherish theories of their
own which are not the truth the truth
does not harmonize with their sentiments
and rather than give up their own ideas
they walk away from those who obey the
truth but there are men who will receive
the truth and these will take the places
made vacant by those who became offended
and leave the truth so it also gives us
this motivation to keep on spreading the
truth yeah for sure and I mean if you
look at this uh you know they had in
jesus' day they they had the prophecy do
you understand that they had they they
understood the pro they knew the Messiah
was coming in that time but they and and
everything that Isaiah said everything
the Old Testament alluded
to in in Isaiah um 53 I think it is yeah
um it happened exactly like that you
know he was mocked he was he had Stripes
you know and and he and he acted exactly
like the Bible said he would but they
neglected the truth they didn't listen
to him because he he he didn't pertain
to their lifestyle and they were
expecting you they were expecting this
Messiah that would Rule and and you know
take them away from captivity from the
Roman power and uh it just goes to show
you know it's all about ourself you know
it's all about me and and it's all about
suiting your own lifestyle and and
unfortunately jumping the gun maybe but
that's
also today in our in our sermons you
know and a lot of the sermons out there
it's all smooth sailing you know don't
offend anybody because then you've got a
problem then we're going to get rid of
you yeah you want to people want to sit
in church to hear things that are
soothing correct that's not going to say
you need to change your life you need to
come in accordance to God's word and you
can't carry on with the things that
you're doing there needs to be a change
there needs to be a conversion there has
to be a conversion exactly and that's
why the The prominent word love is
overused you know yes God is love of
course he's love I mean that is most
important but it's used in a way where
you can where you can live your life of
sin and still be saved in your sin yeah
but and what is true love true love is
getting the people out of the condition
out of the circumstances they're in into
something better into something new
where there's hope yes cuz we you know
you if you if you see the world
deteriorating
you want to help that's what Jesus did
in in 2,000 years ago you know he wanted
to help the people and he was marked in
spaton and and and uh and crucify at the
end oh it's very sad very sad it is it
is and and it also leads to Matthew 24:
11-12 where it says um and many false
prophets shall arise and shall deceive
many and because iniquity shall abound
the love of many shall wax cold it's
exactly what we were talking about you
know there are if I look in the world
today there are there are so many false
revivals you know and it's and it's
becoming more and more prevalent and and
uh people living in pleasure and not
heeding to the word of God anymore but
they Christians they
they they they listen to whatever music
they want they eat whatever they want
they they act in you know they they wful
they are conniving you know all of those
things and they and they forget to to go
back to the root which is Jesus and the
word and see how Jesus um paved the way
for us you know have have you ever heard
this saying from atheists who says they
don't want to be Christians because look
at how Christians act oh
yes so so that shouldn't be the case no
if if you're a Christian there's certain
standards you need to adhere to and
those standards can be found in the
Bible again it's exactly back to the
root because they do not they do not
have the love of the truth yeah and
that's what we're here for we want to
try and walk this road with the viewers
with everyone that to build that
personal relationships with each other
and to discover the truth in the Bible
together correct and I mean
we're not going to heaven alone you know
we are going with each other you know
and we have to be like we said
previously we have to be of one mind and
one spirit and uh Isaiah
8:20 if I may add to the law and to the
testimony if they speak not according to
this word it is because there's no light
in them yeah you know so the testimony
of the testimonies in the Bible you know
of who Jesus isn't that the the you know
the safest place to go to go to the
Bible and people actually you know had a
experience with with God or met Jesus
like you know the gospels that's the
most important uh place to start and to
the law yeah and and yeah we're not
going to get into it now but I mean the
law is it's always it's they always
thought or people think that it's that
is the law that is against us as it says
in Colossians 2 but it's not the law
that's against us that is the ceremonial
laws that go against us so yeah I'm sure
we're going to get into all of those
with all the questions that's going to
come in because those questions are
questions that often come to come to the
front they do yeah and they're important
please please feel free to to ask those
questions yeah sent in those videos and
we didn't say the email address the
email address you can see it on the
screen and it will be truth Clash ofm
minds.com yes yeah oh please send them
in yeah we so so that we can study the
word together and find out what's the
truth yeah yeah and also the Bible is
how we measure what is truth and what is
not yeah but we'll do in one of the
future ones how can we trust the Bible
how can we say this should be our
measure and very soon is it very soon
yeah and is it infallible is this book
infallible
or yeah I believe it is
yeah yeah so but yeah so if we if we go
back to the story of of pilot you know I
believe you had you had have you read it
have you no no I haven't read it yet but
yeah this is where what is truth comes
from that question that was asked and it
was pilate who asked it to Jesus are we
going to read the can I read the the
verse yeah yeah let's let's read the
verse in the Bible yeah okay so it's uh
John chapter 18 18:
37-38 John chapter
18 pilate therefore said unto him art
thou a king then Jesus answered thou
sayest that I'm a king to this end was I
born and for this cause came I into the
world that I should bear witness unto
the truth everyone that is of the truth
heareth my voice pilot said unto him
what is truth and when he had said this
he went out again unto the Jews and says
unto them I find in him no fault at
all so he must have he must have seen
something some Divinity you know just
this man where he cannot find any fault
in him he was a sinful we are all sinful
but I mean he you know he he was about
to crucify Jesus but at the that point
he saw him and he he he Fel and that
those words were really moving to him
you know and we have a behind the scenes
look in the book The Desire of Ages
which is a wonderful book oh yes so
anyone who hasn't read that book we
encourage you to go and read that book
it's amazing you also just the
interesting fact is you find the book in
the Library of Congress as well oh yeah
it's a well-known book yeah it is it is
well the biography of Jesus oh yeah and
in that book it says as he looked at
Jesus pilot now bearing insult and
mockery without retaliation he felt that
he could not be as unrighteous and
unjust as were the clamoring priests um
hoping to gain the truth from him and to
escape the tumult of the crowd pilate
took Jesus aside with him and again
questioned Art Thou the king of the Jews
Jesus did not directly answer this
question he knew that the Holy Spirit
was striving with pilate and he gave him
opportunity to acknowledge his
conviction sayth thou this thing of
thyself he asked or did others tell it
thee of me that is was it the accusation
of the priests or a desire to receive
light from Christ that prompted pilate's
question pilate understood Christ's
meaning but Pride arose in his heart he
would not acknowledge the conviction
that pressed upon Him am I a Jew he said
thine own nation and the chief priest
have delivered thee unto me what hast
thou
done he had the potential of being
stripped from his from his status you
know at that point so obviously choosing
and and that that I'm just jumping to
another you know where the rich man uh
the Young Rich ruler also went away sad
because he had many uh many possessions
you know it's the same thing who you
know he had to choose he had to choose
at that point he had to choose life or
death at that point basically huh you
know so he had to choose remaining the
governor or or um letting Jesus go so so
he didn't have the courage to choose
what is truth exactly yeah I mean sorry
to interrupt but in in in that verse
John 18 it says Jesus says and for this
cause came I into the world that I
should bear witness unto the truth so he
had to reveal what truth is yeah that
distorted image or idea people had about
who God is Jesus came to set the record
straight wonder if pilate ever had read
the Bible the Old Testament or anything
at that point we don't know yeah whether
he had any clue as to the coming Messiah
or whatever but even he saw something
and Jesus where where the
professed um Christians or Jews you know
they they they did not accept Jesus
Christ at all and they had how many
years of reading Moses's writings and
all that and they didn't accept him yeah
that's true and yeah um we can also read
um in just a few paragraphs
below uh in the Desire of Ages paragraph
727 it said Christ affirmed that his
word was in itself a key which would
unlock the mystery to those who were
prepared to receive it it had a self-c
commanding power and this was the secret
of the spread of his kingdom of Truth he
desired pilate to understand that only
by receiving and appropriating truth
could this ruined nature be
reconstructed pilate had a desire to
know the truth his mind was confused he
eagerly grasped the words of the Savior
and his heart was stirred with a great
longing to know what it really was and
how he could obtain it what is truth he
inquired but he did not wait for an
answer the tumult outside recalled him
to the interests of the hour for the
priests were clamorous for immediate
action going out to the Jews he declared
emphatically I find in him no fault at
all I was going to I was going to um
mention that part which was in the in
the verse as well I find in him no fault
at all because he saw this he asked what
what is truth wow you know what I can't
I can't do this to this man you know he
went out and he said I find no fault in
him but then like you said Pride come in
and and he rejected truth yeah and what
happened eventually when he rejected
truth and we read committed suicide yeah
we read that he committed suicide and is
there someone else that also knew the
truth and experienced it daily who also
Reed face to face yeah Judas Judas yeah
himself he also committed suicide yeah
and that's what I was going to say
earlier I forgot is is this this this
this world for decades now it has been
there's
been so much depression and suicide and
mental instability and illnesses and so
forth because truth is being neglected
it's exactly it's exactly that cuz
there's no more there's no more hope
yeah yeah and it's the truth that sets
you free yeah it takes you out of or it
doesn't take you out of the
circumstances you're in but it makes you
able to cope to have that hope
yeah for something better yes correct
and and and what pilot asked let's
address that just briefly I mean he
asked what is truth and I mean there's a
definition in the Bible um I'm going to
read John 17 we are there John 17:1
17 it's very short
verse but it's key for me it's quite key
um says sanctify them through and this
was while uh Jesus was praying to the
father and he was talking you know about
his his um disciples sanctify them
through thy truth Thy word is
truth so if you look at uh if you look
at Psalms
119:1 it says Thou Art near O Lord and
all thy Commandments are truth
so so Commandments word it's it's
synonymous you know what I mean it is so
but then I mean the word if you look at
John 1 verse4 and the Word was made
flesh and dwelt among us and we behold
his glory the glory as of the only
begotten of the father full of grace and
truth so the
word became was made flesh so Jesus
Christ is the word and he showed us the
way on Earth and we rejected him yeah
and I'm looking forward to the rest of
the series and I hope many more people
will join us in this journey yes where
we try and discover the truth from the
Bible me too and and we need to
understand that the Bible is should not
be taken lightly we need to interpret it
correctly you know and we we will do
this together you know we we are all
fallible you know and we we need to we
need to study together and really get
down to the to the and we need to and
how do you study the Bible it's comp
compare scripture with scripture and by
verse line upon line and andit there
here a bit there a little yes and not
all roads lead to
Heaven there's only one narrow road
difficult is the path few are there who
find it if we are not prepared to
sacrifice and abandon what we love in
the sinful world
we don't actually deserve
God yeah so and and and it's actually
very simple cuz once you are here at
this point where you accept Jesus as
your
savior it's actually the only decision
you can make it's the only plausible
decision yeah when when you realize that
truth when you discover you've been
misled and you realize this truth and
you realize the love Jesus has for you
yeah everything this world is just dim
nothing can compare it to his love
exactly and even if they you know there
is deception and there's um Temptations
in this world you leave it behind CU you
know what what God has in store for
us yeah so I guess we I guess we can
conclude this session yeah I I think we
reached the end of our first episode I
do and I'm looking forward to the to the
next ones um and yeah we are uh are you
yeah we're looking forward to the
questions the viewers are going to send
in please do send them in yeah we won't
we won't be able to answer all the
questions we'll try our best to do you
know to to answer as many as possible
but um but yeah please send them in and
and we can just mention as well when
you're taking that video please make
sure it's in an area where there's no um
Echoes and where there's not a lot of
sound in the background or noise
and let's keep it to a minute please so
then maybe we can get more videos in or
more questions in in an episode if it's
short videos sounds good thank you will
you will you close with prayer oh thank
you let's Close Our
Eyes our heavenly father thank you for
this great and wonderful opportunity to
discuss the things that we find in your
word I ask that you will be with all the
viewers everyone out there in the world
who yearns for the truth and who's
looking for something looking for hope I
pray that your holy spirit will lead
them towards the truth and that you will
guide us as we continue the series that
we will also discover truths together
with all the viewers and we can grow
together so please bless us and protect
us until we come together again again
next time in Jesus name I pray amen amen
[Music]
[Applause]